hello everyone and welcome to the second
classical game from the Fida Grand Prix
in Hamburg between alexandra Grisha pin
muxing Rochelle grabbed the first
classical game between the two of them
ended in a draw and these are the
semi-finals so the two of them are
battling it out to see who can reach the
the finest of this a very nice
tournament so without further ado let's
check it out as it is a very nice game
and the other two semi-finalists are
anxious to do the end annealed above so
the two of them
whoever wins between the two of them
will face in the finals whoever wins
between agree shook and MVL so without
further ado grief opens with Knight to
f3 the ready opening is on the board we
have Knight to f6 c4 c5 soul are going
symmetrical and Knight to c3 we have a
strike in the center with d5 seat
captures Knight captures and now III
with East 6 and Bishop to c4 just
developing to to a very nice active
square preparing the castle also d4 at
some point will be played and here we
have Bishop to e7
you could go Knight b6 something like
this but this was proven that it doesn't
really do anything for black yes it
looks like you're stifling White's
development for the moment but what can
either just strike with the d4 and the
white will be perfectly fine or you can
even challenge the c4 pawn would be
three as we always say you should always
attack the the more central pawn Budda
Budda less central pawn you know most of
the times
so after Bishop c4 we have Bishop to e7
both players castles castles castles and
Queen to e2 just nicely developing the
Queen you still have to decide how
you're going to develop this Bishop we
have Knight to c6 and the disposition
has been reached before once in the
shariah grand prix in 2017 between
michael adams in salah salem where adams
was able to win this here the d4 was
played by adams but here rook to d1 is a
new move by critics so already as of
move 9 we have a completely new game we
have b6
strengthen the c5 pawn preparing to
fianchetto the bishop the light square
bishop with d4 and now first Knight
captures on c3
characters and Queen to c7 getting the
Queen away from that D file if it opens
up you don't want the Queen on the same
file as the rook so since the black
allowed it we have E for migration
grabbing more space in the center now
the two points have a very nice central
control loop to d8 and here comes Bishop
to e3 developing the blush of connecting
rooks and were just just playing a very
solid moves with Knight a5 by Maxine
Maxime is a big fan of Knights on the
rim you can see this in all of his games
especially when he plays the groom field
when he plays the groom for very often
he will have a knight on a five and on H
five and he's one of the few people that
can pull this off push her back to d3
and now okay you've it's not that this
diagonal is is a worse diagonal than
this diagonal but when the bishop is on
d3 the rook for the moment that has less
control over the D file Bishop to be
seven black gains control of this very
nice diagonal and now h4 so b5 by Maxine
here he offers the b5 point for the for
the central efore pawn which is usually
the way to go if you can grab a central
point for for a less central pawn then
that will be very good for you and if
you ignore this black will just play a
six on the next more strength and the
pawn structure on the Queen side and
black will be fine
so here green ship says okay with Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now D
captures on c5 offering more traits if
black captures then white will capture
open up an attack on the bishop on e4 so
first maxime will trade the ship
characters queen characters and queen
cap and Bishop captures on c5
you know creating well gaining
equilibrium we're regarding material so
the material on the board is equal but
on the other hand White has a past C
pawn so here
Grigio plays Bishop therefore of course
he doesn't want to trade and he prevents
black from offering further trades
because here for example Bishop d6
doesn't work you just capture it and if
you capture you're getting made it Queen
captures here and that's just it your
your your checkmated so here maxime the
can't continue offering trades so he has
to
the queen queen to be seven attacking
the bishop and now queen back to e to
just defending that bishop we have queen
backed up east seven threatening the age
for pawn but now age five and here you
could try and infiltrate with something
like Queen to h4 but the best of the c7
could be a very dangerous move for white
attacks the night forces a trade along
the D file and if captures captures then
it's a white who's controlling the D
file if it goes up to b6 defending now
we can go Queen to f3 a nice maneuver
that comes with an attack on the roof oh
so you're pressuring f7 so once the rook
moves let's say rook c8 now you play
rook d7 now the hon defending in the
bishop also just threatening f7 so here
white could gain a bit too much if black
is not careful you should not allow a
move like Bishop to c7 so here the
Shabak the d6 now this is possible the
Queen is no longer on f3 so you can
offer a trade here and now English your
trades with a bunch of characters rook
captures we have a lot of trades
captures captures and now rook to d1
gaining control of the D file we have
Queen to c5 attacking the c3 pawn and
here a very exciting moment English says
your well my c3 pawn is not all that
important and here the engines give
something like c h6 which is of course a
move you want to play you want to create
a permanent weakness here along the the
dark square so black will constantly
have to worry about moves like something
like like this if if you create a
weakness and g7 but grip says you can
have my pawn I'm just gonna bring my
rook over to d7 and now that's a very
active rook I always remember when I was
going to through the the the chess
master series I had the chest mastery 11
it was the called chess master 11 grand
masters edition and there we have Josh
Waitzkin Academy and it's really
wonderful stuff yeah Josh Waitzkin talks
about all kinds of end games about how
to play Knight against Bishop I'll play
Bishop against Knight how to play you
know there are a lot of very very nice
topics so if you can get your hands on
at the end if you want to learn more I
you know really recommend it because the
way Josh Waitzkin talks about chess is
just
gonna get you even more interested
interest but here I remember it because
during during that Academy just wait
skin or often will mention how his his
teacher who I believe is bruce
pandolfini called when a rook who goes
to the seventh rank he always said a
look and the seventh is called the pig
so I always remember this when I see a
rook reaching the seventh rank but yeah
dude check it out if you if you have the
opportunity so Queen captures on c3 it's
the strongest move by the engine it's a
free pawn well it's not a free point
white will get development for it but
it's a very strong past C pawn so you do
want to eliminate it
and here the engine will give Queen to
efore as the main idea just attacks the
rook positions the Queen to a much much
more central square and after rook
retreats the faith you don't want to
allow any tricks against the f7 pawn now
h6 g6 and we kind of get the the
position that we were discussing where
black will have to play the rest of the
game with the Queen guarding this
diagonal because if you are more like
Queen e5 to threaten checkmate then it's
basically over you're gonna have to open
up the King even more and dad that's
just it
so that's one idea Bishop has a
definitely a queen d1 he's threatening
rook to b8 which will result in mate
so h6 now not allowing h6 by white also
creating an escape route for the key for
the King and now g3 white does the same
we have roped f8 and now comes rope
captures an a7 there was no way to keep
guarding the a7 pond so good issue just
picks it up and here of course now you
gave up the C c3 pawn basically for your
past a pawn but on the other hand here
black has here the two weaknesses are
basically the f7 point and the the past
a pawn these are blacks weaknesses even
though okay the DA pawn is White's pawn
but it would be maybe stronger if you
had this weakness to worry about and
also if this pawn was on h6 and you had
the dark square weaknesses to worry
about but okay Knight to c6 getting the
knight back into the game with rook to
d7 and now Knight to e5 centralizing the
night
we looked back to d8 now offering the
trade we have Queen to c7 or forcing the
trade to happen on a fate so rook
captures King captures and now I don't
have to tell you what you do when you
have a past a pawn it's an outside
passport material in the world is equal
but leadership has an outside pass pawn
so of course he will push it with a four
and kink the e7 centralizing the King
improving the position of the king with
Bishop back to e - now before continuing
to push you're a pawn you want a you
want to defend everything properly you
want you want this to be protected you
want your King and not have any
weaknesses you don't want allow the
black Queen any checks we have to worry
about them so first you're gonna have to
improve your position as as much as
possible before deciding to put your
past a pawn queen the c3 just a better
square for the Queen guarding the a5
squares so you cannot pull the pawn with
Queen to be one now with ideas of
bringing the Queen over to b5 as now the
Bishop coverage the h5 pawn and then you
hope to start pushing your passport
we have Knight back the c6 now guarding
the a5 square twice and now Queen b7
check we have King has to go back if you
want to keep an eye on the f7 pawn King
f6 and now better back the f1 we have a
nice day a5 attacking the Queen the
forcing the Queen to move Queen to d7
and here it doesn't seem like white
white has an opportunity to start
advancing the pawns because how are you
ever going to move this pawn the knight
is I'm a dark square you have a light
square bishop you can't really force
that nice to move but on the other hand
black doesn't have all that many useful
moves you cannot move the Queen from
this diagonal you could well you could
but you you have to keep an eye on the
night if you allow Queen d8 check here
you're gonna lose that night so the
Queen doesn't have all that many moves
so here
Maxime goes for g5 he either says okay
I'm either getting more space on the
Kings side or you have to trade once
here Girish of trades characters
captures and now King to g2
improving the position of the King came
back to g7 and now Bishop to b5 again
asking black what do you play
so Queen to e5 Maxime says I can hold
this
this is this is another problem we have
queen 2 D 3 and now comes Queen to c5
just waiting to see what will happen but
the good issue has a plan he wants to
play Queen f3 and Bishop at the aid to
go after the f7 pawn so here we have
Queen to f3 preparing Bishop to I ate
Queen to d4 and now rush of the 8 now
forcing forcing a trade of Queens
there's no other a good way to defend
this
you could try quinta a7 although then
you then you if quinta a7 it could be
could be something like Bishop captures
on f7 just because you still have this
check which would pick up the night
so you basically win a pawn Queen
captures sorry Queen captures on f7
Queen c3 check and now you just trade
you pick up the night and then you have
three to two advantage with a passed
pawn it's it's a winning game game so
here
Queen to d5 the only good defensive move
we have Queen captures pawn captures and
now came to f3 here white starts to
bring the King into the game King if six
Maxime does the same King to g4
preparing to play King h5 go after the
pawn and now came to East 7 forcing the
bishop back very important you don't
want to weaknesses so Bester back to b5
and now came back to f6 preparing King G
7th to guard the h6 pawn king h5 with
King g7 and now Bishop back to f1 and
it's very interesting how the game
continues from this point which you'll
see we have Knight to b3 and Bishop to
g2 now attacking the the pawn here d4
and now Bishop back to f1 so here the
the bishop is not allowing the point
across the d3 Square and you cannot
really move the night away from b3
because you don't want to allow a5 a6
and so on
so here we have Knights to d2 first or
attacking the bishop Bishop to d3 and
not knight back to b3 Maxime is happy
with a draw here he is guarding the a5
square
but the shabak the f1 night the d2 and
Bishop to d3 we have a repetition of
moves a few few times Knight to b3 and
now of course agree sure who does not
want to end this with a threefold
repetition so he goes back Bishop to b5
and now there is a problem here you
cannot
hold onto everything you can't if you
move the night for example if you move
the night anywhere then you allow a five
so the night has to keep an eye on the a
five square on the other hand if you
play Knight to the a five which is the
only other viable option then you get to
keep the g4 and this is the problem King
of six king of four King g6 King here
and now you can see that the point is
under attack if you don't want to lose
the pawn you cannot play Knight to c6 to
guard it the bishop covers that's where
and you cannot play Knight to b3 because
of Bishop to c4 check that's just just a
really big problem here so here we have
f6 it's just a useless move but it is
better than than playing what would you
just see but here Grisha plays a very
nice triangulation with the bishop to
get this exact same position but to give
black the move so he repeats brush of
two f1 Knight to a5 we have Bishop back
to a6 Knight to b3
and now Russia back the b5 so we get
this exact same position that we had
when the pawn was on f7 but now you
don't have a useful move if you try if
you try and waste more moves with f5
it's not gonna help white can play f3
and at some point you're gonna even
either either have to move the King or
move the knight so here maxime goes for
Knight to a5 it's the strongest move by
the engine but it's regardless of that
it's just a losing idea because now the
same idea applies King g4 and now we
already shown that this doesn't work if
you try advancing your King because the
Bishop to c4 will always be able to kick
away the night from b3 regardless of is
there Czech or is there no check so nice
the b7 maxeen finds a different way on
how to prevent the aggressive skin from
approaching King a4 and non Knight the
c5 and here the night and pawns create a
wall against the black King so you
cannot approach the pawn but you've
abandoned your guarding of the a5
squares so a5 now you can finally start
pushing your passport
we have d3 and keep the e3 now not
allowing pawn to d2 but d2 nonetheless
and here I hope none of you were
thinking about capturing it if you
capture it just might be three check
picks up the pawn so that would be
would be pretty bad for white but yeah
I'm just kidding her I know none of you
were actually thinking about capturing
at the pond so Bishop to e2 by Greece
shook and it was in this position
unmoved 63 that Maxim vasila Grove
resigned the game and Grisha press you
know advances to the finals so Grisha
keys in the finals of the fede Grand
Prix in Hamburg he waits for the winner
of the match between youngster Duda and
Anil dubov and here he resigns because
well Maxime resigns because after
anything well let's say king g6 you know
you can't move the knight and allow the
phone to go forward now this the
difference is you can actually capture
the pawn and this is just you know the
icing on the top because after Knight b3
checking c3 Knight cat Knight captures
you will play Bishop to f3 and the
knight is trapped you cover these two
squares and the King covers these two
squares so none of the squares that the
knight can go to our are available to
the night next move your ears won't like
King before and capture the night what
there's nothing black can do about it
we can show King g5 king before whatever
let's say h5 f5 doesn't really matter
King captures and now let's say Bishop
to g2 you create a wall against the
black King and you kill the black King
can can never you know approach the pawn
White has all the time in the world to
go back and you know create a create a
winning plan which is not all that
difficult
so after Bishop to e2 maxime resigns and
again a tough tough break for Maxim
holograph who who is always very close
to qualifying for the candidates but but
not quite there but there is one more
leg of the Fida grand prix well he where
he will have his opportunity as it
doesn't seem all that likely that he
will catch any giri you know reading
ratings wise so he will still have his
opportunity in the in the last leg of
the feeding grand prix so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Pawan Karim Shetty for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos thank
you for watching and I will see soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
Grand Prix the fight between do both and
do that and then of course the finals of
the of the feeder Grand Prix checking up
on yours
and still preparing our next big saga so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day